coming up next week in Brussels a packed
week of you in sexy generals presidents
prime ministers tea tip and a milli
plenary welcome to the agenda bringing
grandeur to a packed mini plenary
session in Brussels at the UN section
General Ban ki-moon his Excellency has
spoken of his concern over instability
in Libya and the growing migrant crisis
as Europe readies itself to plunge at
Navy ships into the Mediterranean waters
to go after smugglers kid banking moon
have stern words also look out for
debates on the June g7 summit stopping
cyber attacks against the media like the
one on tv5 monde and forced marriages
she's our country's first female
president but as Catherine's amber
Panzer makes her way to the Parliament
the question for many is the endgame in
sight for the conflict in the Central
African Republic a historic peace deal
was brokered between her government and
armed rebel factions at the beginning of
May under the agreement rebel groups
must disarm renounce violence scientists
may also be absorbed into the army but
peace deals between previous governments
and militias have failed is this one
different find out more on Tuesday it
was a launching pad for the Arab Spring
and won a few success stories but as
disenchantment brings people back onto
the streets could Tunisia like Egypt
sees Democratic flowering stamped out
protests erupted remembers of a former
Ben Ali regime were given lient
sentences Oh release from jail Europe
has a vested interest in the country as
it provides technical and financial
assistance watch the debate with Prime
Minister her believe a seat on Thursday
and finally the last words go to tea tip
the trade committee report which details
Parliament's position on the
transatlantic trade and investment
partnership goes to a final vote at the
committee kid is ds4 divisive private
arbitration clause be finally showing
the door we'll find out on Thursday and
that's all we have for this agenda take
care and enjoy the week